[Music]
[Applause]
better check the barn door flip I think
the horses got now hearty crossover
pulls back Shakalaka to puts it up
Moxon James Harden nails the two pointer
this is not a great possession but
an absolute big-time play by heart
[Applause]
yes one of the store
after yoga
the step-back three
gorgeous jacquard
jumps it up
[Applause]
back to heart hardened dominance
[Music]
[Applause]
great job by the Rockets a break in the
playoff Jeremy Lin did not come off and
they just let James go right up and get
the ball second down to four three down
to two
none fear cold-blooded free to win the
game that's it everybody go home
especially Houston fans go happy one
point Golden State lead
[Applause]
we looked at sleemoth shot clock at four
seconds down to three
[Applause]
we're cookin now
pardon Murray switches off Florida
shooting
pardon shake-and-bake steps back
reporter curry may I have this dance
82 combines between a heart and 45
as he drains another step back three
that's a half a hundy for headband
haunted